let's say I wanted to find the volume of
a cube where the values of the cube
let's say X is between X is greater than
or equal to zero is less than or equal
to I don't know three let's say Y is
greater than or equal to zero and is
less than or equal to four and then
let's say that Z is greater than or
equal to zero n is less than or equal to
two now I know using basic geometry you
could figure out you know just met just
multiply the width times the height
times the depth then you'd have the
volume but I want to do this example
just so that you get used to what a
triple integral looks like how it
relates to a double integral and then
later in the next video we could do
something slightly more complicated so
let's just draw that this volume so this
is my x-axis so my z axis this is the y
X Y Z X Y Z okay so X is between zero
and three so that's X is equal to 0 this
is X is equal to say 1 2 3 y is between
0 & 4 1 2 3 4 so in the XY plane it
looks something like this the kind of
base of our cube will look something
like this and then Z is between 0 to 2
so 0 is the xy-plane and then 1/2 so
this would be the top part and I'll
maybe I'll do that in a slightly
different color so this is along the x z
axis you'd have a boundary here and then
it would come in like this if a boundary
here come in like that boundary there
then like that so we want to figure out
the volume of this cube and you could do
it you could say well this is the the
depth is 3 the base the width is 4 so
this area is 12 times the height 12
times 2 is 24 you could say it's 20 for
the cubic units whatever units were
doing but let's do it as as a triple
integral so what is a triple integral
mean what we can do is we could say we
can take the the smart the volume of a
very small I don't want to say area of a
very small volume so let's say I wanted
to take the volume of a
small cube someplace in this the volume
under question and it'll start to make
more sense or it starts to become a lot
more useful when we have variable
boundaries and surfaces and curves as
boundaries but let's say we want to
figure out the volume of this little
small cube here
that's my cube it's someplace in this
larger cube this larger rectangle cubic
rectangle whatever you want to call it
so what's the volume of that cube let's
say that it's its width is dy its width
is dy so that length right there is dy
its height is DX all right now its
height is DZ right the way I drew it Z
is up up and down and then its depth is
DX this is DX so this is DX this is DZ
this is dy so you could say that the
small volume when this larger volume you
can call that DV which is kind of the
volume differential and that would be
equal to you could say it's just the
width times the length times the height
dy a DX times dy times DZ and you could
switch the orders of these right because
multiplication is associative and order
doesn't matter and all of that but
anyway what can you do with it in here
well we can we can take the integral we
get integrals all integrals help us do
is it helps us take infinite sums of
infinitely small distances like a DZ or
DX or dy is let cetera so what we can do
is we could take this cube and first add
it up and let's say the Z direction so
we can take that cube and then add it
and then add it along up the up and down
axis the z axis so we get the volume of
a column so what would that look like
well since we're going up and down we're
adding we're taking the sum in the z
direction we'd have an integral and then
what's art what's the lowest Z value
well it's Z is equal to zero Z equal to
zero and let's say the upper bet like if
you were to just take keep adding these
cubes and keep going up you would run
into the upper bound and what's the
upper bound its Z is equal to two Z is
equal to two and of course you would
take the sum of these DVS
I'll write DZ first just so it
reminds us that we're going to take the
integral with respect to Z first and
let's say well do Y next and then we'll
do X so this integral this value as I
have written it we'll figure out the
volume of a column given any X and y
it'll be a function of x and y but since
we're dealing with all constant here
it's actually going to add be a constant
value it'll be it'll be the VAT the
constant value of the volume of one of
these columns and it'll essentially be
will be two times dy/dx because the
height of one of these columns is 2 and
then its width and its depth is dy and
DX so then if we want to figure out the
entire volume so what we did just now is
we figured out the height of a column so
then we could take those columns and sum
them in the y-direction right so for
summing in the y-direction we could just
take another integral of this sum in the
Y direction and Y goes from zero to what
Y goes from zero to four
I wrote this integral a little bit too
far to the left looks strange but I
think you get the idea Y is equal to 4 y
y is equal to 0 to Y is equal 4 and then
that'll give us the volume of kind of a
sheet that is parallel to the zy plane
and then all we have to left left to do
is add up a bunch of those sheets in the
X direction we'll have the volume of our
entire figure so to add up those sheets
we would have to sum in the X direction
and we'd go from X is equal to 0 to X is
equal to 3 and to evaluate this it's
actually fairly straightforward so first
we're taking the integral with respect
to Z well we don't have anything written
in under here but we can just assume
that there's a 1 right because DZ times
dy times DX is the same thing as 1 times
DZ times dy DX so what's the value of
this integral well the antiderivative of
one it with respect to Z is just Z right
because the derivative of Z is 1 and you
evaluate that from 2 to 0 so then you're
left with so it's 2 minus 0 so you just
left with 2 so you're left with 2 and
you take the integral of that from Y is
equal to 0 to Y is equal to 4 dy and
then you have
X from X is equal to 0 to X is equal to
3 DX and notice when we just took the
integral with respect to Z we ended up
with a double integral and this double
integral is the exact integral we would
have done in the previous videos on the
double integral where you would have
just said well Z is a function of x and
y so you could have written you know Z
is a function of x and Y is always equal
to 2 it's a constant function it's
independent of x and y but if you had
defined Z in this way and you wanted to
figure out the volume under this surface
where the surface is Z is equal to 2 you
know this is the surface Z is equal to 2
we would have ended up with this so you
see that what we're doing with the
triple integral it's really really
nothing different and you might be
wondering well why are we doing it at
all and I'll show you that in in a
second
anyway to evaluate this you could you
know take the antiderivative of this
with respect to Y you get 2y let me
scroll down a little bit you get 2y
evaluating that at 4 and 0 and then so
you get 2 times 4 so it's 8 minus 0 and
then you integrate that from with
respect to X from 0 to 3 so that's 8 X
from 0 to 3 so that'll be equal to 24
units cute so I know the obvious
question is what is this good for well
when you have constant when you have a
kind of a constant value within the
volume you're right you could have just
done a double integral but what if I
were told you our goal is not to figure
out the volume of this figure our goal
is to figure out the mass of this figure
and even more this this this this volume
this area of space or whatever its mass
is not uniform if its mass was uniform
you could just you know multiply its its
uniform density times its volume and you
would get its mass but let's say the
density changes it could be a volume of
some gas or it could be even you know
some material with different compounds
in it so let's say that its density is a
variable function of XY and Z so let's
say that the density this Rho this thing
that looks like a P is what you normally
use in physics for density so its
density as a function of
X Y & Z let's just to make it simple
let's make it X times y times Z so if we
wanted to figure out if we wanted to
figure out the mass of any small volume
it would be that volume times the
density right because density the units
of density are like you know kilograms
per meter cubed so if you multiply it
times meter cubed you get kilograms so
we could say that the mass I'll make up
notation D mass this isn't a function
well I don't write a parenthesis it
makes look a function so the a very a
differential of mass or a very small
mass is going to equal the density at
that point which would be XYZ times the
volume of that of that small mass and
that volume of that small mass we could
write as DV and we know that DV is the
same thing as the width times the height
times the depth DV doesn't always have
to be DX times dy times DZ if we're
doing other coordinates if we're doing
polar coordinates it could be something
slightly different and we'll do that
eventually but if we want to figure out
the mass since we're using rectangular
coordinates it would be the density
function at that point times that our
differential volume so x DX dy DZ and of
course we can change the order here so
when you want to figure out the volume
so we're going to figure out the mass
which I will do in the next video we
essentially will have to integrate this
function as opposed to just 1 over Z Y
and X and I'm going to do that in the
next video and you'll see that it's
really just a lot of basic taking anti
derivatives and avoiding careless
mistakes I will see you in the next
video